morning all the controversial national
insurance increase is
set to go ahead after boris johnson made
a firm commitment to bring it in in
april after days of reportedly wobbling
on the policy the prime minister and the
chancellor rishi sunak have said this
morning that it is the right plan
so from this april national insurance
contributions will increase by 1.25
percent to
13.25
from next april that rise will become a
new separate health and social care levy
but what does that mean for your
finances
well people earning 20 000 pounds a year
will pay an extra 89 pounds in national
insurance
for employees on 30 000 annually they'll
pay an extra 214 pounds
and for those earning 50 000 their
payment will go up by
464 pounds
the government estimates that the
national insurance increase will raise
around 12 billion pounds in extra
funding for health and social care
political correspondent rob powell
standing by in westminster
morning again rob just just reading the
the joint byline piece uh the
co-authored piece by the chancellor and
the prime minister they both are at
great pains to point out that they are
in favor of tax cuts and that they are
indeed thatcherites which which suggests
that there might be a few people within
their own party considering them not to
be
yeah i think uh there is an attempt to
reassure worried conservative
backbenchers who uh have been calling on
the prime minister and chancellor to act
uh as they see it more like
conservatives by cutting taxes and not
putting them up within this piece i
think it's notable that this is a joint
piece from the prime minister and the
chancellor there's been weeks really of
rumblings about a degree of divisional
rift
between
them
especially potentially over this policy
but it is now confirmed 1.25 percent for
employees but also of course 1.25
up uh national insurance for em
employees uh for employers as well sorry
um and what they say in this piece in
the sunday times is that we must clear
the covered backlogs with our plan for
health and social care and now is the
time to stick to that plan we must go
ahead with the health and social care
levy it is the right plan they then go
on though this is the reassurance bit i
think we are tax cutting conservatives
we are thatcherites in the sense that we
believe in sound money there is no magic
money tree
uh so i think that last bit is clearly
designed to reassure wobbling
backbenchers um i think some of the
speculation about
this tax rise essentially being shelved
could be put down to boris johnson
attempting to shore up his position amid
all of the allegations of number 10
parties you can probably read into it
slightly that the fact that he has
decided to now commit to it after a week
of not explicitly committing to it
suggests that he thinks he still has the
political strength and authority to
carry his party through this i think it
also piles more pressure though on the
government to do something elsewhere in
the sort of polish policy spectrum about
the cost of living because if they're
not going to act this tax rise and
energy bills are set to go up
substantially in april many will still
be wanting them to put some sort of
support in place to help people with
everyday
cost of living
it's going to be a busy week i think you
can expect potentially something on that
on cost of living you're also going to
get the leveling up white paper the plan
uh a key part of boris johnson's policy
offering coming on wednesday and plenty
of movement around ukraine and visits
being made by the prime minister to the
region and some of his senior ministers
as well so a kind of jam-packed agenda
for the prime minister i think on a
political level he will be happy though
that the spotlight is on those big
issues rather than necessarily
accusations of number 10 parties of
course we're still waiting for that
report from the senior civil servant sue
gray to go to number 10 and then be
published we certainly are rob thanks
very much indeed
uh well the prime minister uh is
considering doubling the number of uk
troops to europe's borders his fears
grow of a russian invasion of ukraine
boris johnson says his new offer to nato
will send a clear message to the kremlin
that the west would not tolerate
russia's destabilizing activity if
quotes
it chooses a path of bloodshed and
destruction
in a statement from number 10 the prime
minister confirmed that the uk is
considering doubling nato troop numbers
it's also considering sending defensive
weapons to estonia where it already has
900 military personnel and jets warships
and military specialists to protect nato
allies skies joe pike
reports the war of the airwaves is
almost as important as the battle on the
ground
and the message in this footage from the
ukrainian military training with uk
anti-tank missiles in the west of the
country is of readiness
joe biden has now warned in a call with
the country's president there is a
distinct possibility of a russian
invasion next month
boris johnson has now announced a new
offer of troops fast jets and warships
to support nato allies that's before the
pm's call with vladimir putin and his
trip to the region in the coming days
mr johnson has said i have ordered our
armed forces to prepare to deploy across
europe next week ensuring we are able to
support our nato allies on land at sea
and in the air
liz truss who met the nato secretary
general on monday will travel to moscow
in the next fortnight
and defense secretary ben wallace here
in berlin on wednesday is due to visit
hungary slovenia and croatia
frankly
i think it is reasonably unlikely that
he would attempt to conquer all of
ukraine by force the ukrainians will
fight and as much as putin likes to talk
about the friendship the historic links
between the people of ukraine and russia
ever since 2014 we have seen a steady
increase
in i won't say anti-russian attitudes in
ukraine but anti-putin attitudes
whitehall may have been focused on one
political crisis for weeks but here at
the foreign office they've been trying
to prevent another the pm wants to be
seen as a statesman spearheading the
west's efforts this is also a convenient
distraction from domestic disarray boris
johnson is vladimir putin's fifth uk
prime minister and it's perfectly
possible the russian president will soon
get a sixth
as further russian military vehicles
arrive in belarus and reports suggest
blood supplies and medical equipment are
among that build up boris johnson has
asked his defense chiefs to finalize
details of their deployment in case
vladimir putin does what so many fear
joe pike sky news
busy morning on the channel the foreign
secretary liz truss is a guest on trevor
phillips on sunday uh sir trev will also
be speaking to the shadow secretary of
state for communities and local
government lisa nandy and the kremlin
critic bill browder that is starting at
half past eight
a second major storm is on its way
across the uk after storm malik left two
dead and thousands without electricity
a falling tree killed a woman in
aberdeen and a nine-year-old boy in
staffordshire
people in scotland and northern england
are facing more problems as storm carry
moves in later today there is still a
red alert from the power companies for
the north of scotland they're dealing
with 200 incidents and around 23 000
homes still without power
the latest figures from northern power
grid say a further 26 000 homes are
without power in northern england this
morning
also 600 reports of damage across
england with the north of the country
suffering the most sky's becky caution
reports now from rothbury in
northumberland
queuing in the freezing cold for a hot
meal a local fish and chip van and its
generator making sure most here were fed
storm alex damage coming to rothbury not
long after storm arwin's brutality we
have had some residents yet again that
have been without
emergency service
access via their mobiles or landlines
there was good news though the
electricity came back
but with storm corey now on its way this
town like so many others is still
vulnerable
and tens of thousands of houses are
still without power
malik has battered much of northern
england and scotland in appley bridge in
west yorkshire a driver was fortunate to
walk away from this
firefighters in greater manchester
rescued a woman from her car after a
tree had crashed through its roof
but in aberdeen a 60 year old woman was
killed by a falling tree
winds of more than 100 miles per hour
have been recorded in parts of scotland
with several a-roads shut in
aberdeenshire and major disruption to
the rail timetable
property and power lines had been
destroyed
in a statement northern power grid said
storm malik is causing disruption to our
network as it continues to move across
our operating area
our teams are responding restoring power
through alternative routes on our
network where possible assessing damage
and coordinating repairs wherever
conditions permit
and now as a new storm rolls in there is
a yellow weather warning in place for
scotland and northern england
becky cottrell sky news northumberland
storm corey is due to hit the uk later
today and we will of course keep you up
to date with its progress here on sky
news uh the met office says a low
pressure system will be bringing very
strong winds to scotland later gusts of
70 to 80 potentially even 90 miles an
hour in exposed coastal locations and
mountainous areas
then as storm corey clears to the east
on monday the weather will remain
blustery at the start of the week
i want to find out more from jim dale
senior meteorologist at the british
weather services jim great to have you
on the program this morning um
let's start with them at storm malik
shall we just explain exactly
where you would see that as ranking in
terms of the the storms that we have
seen over the past couple of years
people have lost their lives thousands
of homes remain without power an awful
lot of damage but but this is the time
of year that we're going to get things
like this
yeah it it kind of in the winter is has
gone we started with a couple of storms
has already been mentioned
and another one that followed and then
um we kind of fell into a gap if you
like almost a sedate nothingness uh
where winter was passing us by and not
what was happening and there was always
going to be a return to something of
this nature once the high pressure
system that's been over us for so long
moved away it did uh and these these
storms uh malik was actually named by
the the danish uh mess institute rather
than our own met office um we had these
warnings out on thursday for for the for
this particular storm malik and um
obviously it did its stuff on on
saturday and now we've got the next one
coming in uh corey and they look very
similar on a magnitude of a scale i
don't think this is like the the 1987
october storm which ravaged the the
southern uh parts of the uk
um but it's certainly you know when it
does the kind of damage we've seen and
and lives lost then then it's it's
ranking right up there in terms of the
danger and the hazards that are
associated
and of course uh all of our eyes now
turning to the horizon to see a storm
corey uh holding interview yeah
to be honest with you as a meteorologist
you look at the malik one and you look
at this one they look the same uh the
same path the same potential wind
strength so um it's not now i mean the
people if people are waking up now and
you know walking outside and whatever
they're thinking what's going on because
there's not a lot going on it's again
the calm before the storm um so this is
really going to going to sort of ramp up
as we go through the course of the
afternoon but particularly the evening
and the overnight period and into monday
morning as you pointed out um and that's
going to be the stress period when we
see the highest gusts and particularly
across scotland northeast england we've
got we got the amber warning actual fact
for northeast england and scotland as a
whole it's very hard to differentiate
between the the different parts of
scotland who's going to get what but i
think it's that eastern straight
certainly over the higher ground um
highlands and grampians and as as you've
mentioned already the coastal plains
which tend to see the highest highest of
the gusts and of course we should we
should also um pay some attention to
that which is happening in the united
states
we've got you and your your expertise
the east coast looking pretty grim at
the moment what on earth is a bomb
cyclone yeah it's it's the north
easterly going into uh into the the uh
northeast parts of the united states
it's a the clue's in the in the name
bomb um everything happening at once uh
putting down a lot of snow
um
and when i say a lot i don't just mean a
couple of inches we're talking feet of
snow so it's basically uh
two the air mass is meeting essentially
with a lot of moisture involved in an
area of low pressure deep area low
pressure sitting off that northeast
coast of um
of america so it's pushing in all the
all the the the mixture if you like the
moisture the humidity uh the contents of
both of those things very high and it's
just dumping dumping lots and lots of
snow as the cold air pushes in so it's
that mixture as you get that often
happens i say often not that often that
that it becomes newsworthy this is a
this is a newsworthy event to say the
least if this was the uk we'd be buried
and i think those northeastern states
are probably seeing some of that right
now jim great to have your expertise on
the program this morning oh and by the
way i do love that book uh just over
your shoulder there jim dale senior
meteorologist at british weather
services great to see you thanks for
joining us you're welcome
uh well now let's speak to robert coburn
he's emergency response manager for red
cross scotland and joins us now robert
again good to have you on the program
this morning um i've got to say you
don't generally think when you hear of
the red cross of of them helping out in
this country but of course you do so at
times of need i mean how bad have things
been where you are
um
well it's
it's been pretty bad over this last kind
of couple of days
but obviously you know we had storm
irwin a few weeks ago um the people are
generally pretty nervous i mean the
biggest impact we've found has been
settled from
my leg has certainly been the
in the north of the country the forecast
for today is as your chat from the met
office has said is
kind of more widespread across islands
western isles the grampian east coast
kind of areas so yeah it's
it's been busy and we were certainly had
volunteers like yesterday visiting homes
in the grampian area under now kind of
welfare kits and we are ready and on
standby to do more today
for today and tomorrow if required well
indeed yeah carrie is on the way and
robert can we just be specific what what
is it exactly the red cross do at times
like this you can have alluded to it
there going out checking perhaps on more
vulnerable members of the community
getting some food out to them but i'm
sure there's more than that
um yeah i mean it generally it kind of
gets wrapped up in what we refer to as a
welfare visit so
um we will visit people in their homes
um check that they're okay or as okay as
they can be deliver
you know some basic supplies around kind
of snacks water
blankets gloves hats you know these
types of things
we can also work with our um local
authority partners who will very often
in extreme situations they will sell
what they call rest centers
where people can come
you know as opposed to
living the storm out at home they can
come to a rest center
where you know again well volunteers in
there who will help people
help
find a more practical and more emotional
support on to them so that you know it's
about getting through the storm
well
and as mentioned robert um another one
on the way i accidentally called it
storm carry i don't know why on earth i
did that perhaps thinking of another
story but storm corey i mean how
concerned are you
um
well i mean
all of these things you know anything is
weather you can you know you can do your
preparation um
and then you just have to sit and wait
what happens see what happens when it
actually hits um there's lots of things
that people can do in preparing so for
this afternoon for example prepare to be
staying at home don't you know if you
don't have to go then certainly don't go
out um have things like your mobile
phone charged
have available you know kind of battery
powered kit like radios and torches just
in case you get a power outage um
have easy to
you know easy to prepare smacks in the
house bottles of water um look out the
winter downey that you know
you might have just a spare one tucked
away get outside so that you know
you can hunker down for you know the
next kind of 24 hours if required um
keep an eye on the on the the weather
reports they will keep you best
appraised as to what's likely to happen
next
um well robert uh wishing you and your
colleagues uh all the best of luck as
you work over the next couple of days
robert coleman from the red cross really
appreciate your time
thank you
but of course as we were mentioning uh
just a couple of minutes ago in the
united states a massive storm is
bringing dangerous snow across the east
coast that could last for several days
our u.s correspondent greg milam has the
story
the east coast of the united states is
no stranger to extreme weather but this
is a winter storm of a strength way
beyond even what they're used to times
square in new york blanketed in snow and
treacherous conditions stretching across
10 states up and down the coast an area
home to 75 million people the mayor of
new york out early to record his own
advice for residents
so be careful bundle up good day to stay
home if you don't have to go out
it is massachusetts being hit hardest
isolated areas expected to get up to
three feet of snow before this storm has
passed
couple that with wind gusts reaching
hurricane force in some places the
concern that blizzards could cause
white-out conditions
i want to make sure everyone understands
this even though there might be a little
break or you start seeing a little
clearing don't be don't be misled by
that there could be a gust of wind that
creates whiteout conditions while you're
out in the store running to get that
last gallon of milk you want to get
hopefully everybody gets these in
advance so this is not a time to be out
there shopping the stormers hit air
travel too at a deserted logan airport
in boston the departure board telling
the story of some of the thousands of
flights cancelled
it is areas closest to the coast that
are seeing some of the worst conditions
residents told to move to higher ground
with an expectation of severe flooding
for others there's little to do but wait
it out well i'm gonna stay safe is once
we get home we want to
stay in the house put our jammies on and
hot cocoa coffee watch some movies relax
and chill
they call these storms nor'easters
caused by what's known as a bomb cyclone
this is the first major blizzard to hit
the east coast for four years and one
they won't forget in a hurry greg milam
sky news
vulnerable five to 11 year olds become
eligible today for their first covered
19 jab
some 500 000 children in the age bracket
who are either at risk from covert or
live with someone who is will now be
able to come forward and get vaccinated
many have had to be kept isolated
because the risk to them from covid is
so severe
quick look at the latest data 72
727 new cases were confirmed in the last
24-hour period a further 296 deaths were
recorded taking the total number within
28 days of a positive test to 155
6613
as the uk tries to reach net zero
emissions by 2050 could going jet zero
be the answer an airfield in surrey has
become the uk's first flying school to
offer pilot training on
fully electric aircraft with hopes that
it could be the future of aviation skies
shingi maruriki has been taking a look
it's time for takeoff but not like
you've ever seen it before
charged up and ready to go the uk's
first ever fully electric training plan
flight school involved hope that by
cutting down carbon and noise this could
be a huge leap for sustainable air
travel the future is is going electric
and going green and so you know this is
the first step towards a training
aircraft and it's important that people
learn to fly with us and this is going
to be the new technology so it's a
conventional aircraft so we have a
central control stick here sam has flown
for more than 30 years
and after more than 16 000 air miles
he's never had an hour in the sky like
that one
but there will be challenges
the charging infrastructure like it is
with with cars you know has to be grown
to make it a sustainable thing
electric flights like these are meant to
be the future they're cleaner quieter
and eventually they'll be able to go
further too in the race to jet zero
commercial airliners are also exploring
similar options
that change will take some time though
30 years away until we till we do we
finish this thing properly
and engineers like me we've got a
mountains climb to make it happen and i
can't wait to trade up to electricity
but we've got a lot of work to do and
it's something that we can and must do
as well
it might be a while until electric
planes take off everywhere but here that
idea has already arrived shinki marike
sky news blackbush airport
so should we be expecting clear skies
today let's find out
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
storm corey will bring gales to northern
western and central parts later today
there's a met office amber warning for
wind over northern scotland with 90 mile
an hour gusts possible in exposed spots
yellow warnings are in place for other
northern areas at the moment though it
is mainly dry calm and frosty the
morning will stay mostly fine but
northwest scotland ireland and northern
ireland will turn windy as patchy rain
moves in there will be coastal gales in
the northwest it will be a little bit
cooler scotland northern ireland and
ireland will have a spell of prolonged
rain and some mountain snow during the
afternoon
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now we tried to speak to him yesterday
but we were a few technical issues so we
know now return to the young man who has
quite literally gone the extra mile to
give his classmates a brand new school
playground yesterday
six-year-old
bear that in mind harvey goodman
embarked on a 15-mile hike from his
primary school to old trafford all part
of a bid to raise money for a new
playground let's take a quick look at
him
reaching the finishing line
[Applause]
and i am very pleased to say that harvey
joins us on the program alongside his
mum naomi guys lovely to see you this
morning um
harvey am i right in saying that you ran
the last bit of the 15 miles there were
you not tired
no
you weren't
why not
because
because i was going to have a party in
the hotel football
well if anything is going to make you
run it's going to be the prospect of a
party and a game of football but why
were you doing this in the first place i
am told it was because you wanted to get
a new playground for you and your
friends
yes
and what type of playground do you want
to get what right what do you want to
see in your new playground some pits
i want to see a month's kitchen
pipes
i need
a digging area i need a wellie store i
need a hideout place in the bushes even
i need two big craters
no roller coaster you know nothing like
that that might just be a little bit too
dangerous is it
no
no no definitely not well let's let's
have a quick word with uh with mum naomi
good to see you this morning as well you
must be so proud of this wee guy 15
miles and and how much money have you
raised so far
uh we're over 7 000. i think it's
7130 it was this morning when we last
checked so yeah so proud he's done
amazing all the training that's gone
into it and then you know uh obviously
doing the big walk yesterday um it was
great
i i take it here as a man you fan yeah
huge my new fan oh dear i knew there was
gonna be something that was going to
take the sheen off his performance this
morning um but what why the need for the
new playground we obviously we we tried
to speak yesterday and we had some
technical difficulties we couldn't get
to the board so what what why the need
for the new playground i mean obviously
you know playground for for children is
is uh is you know it's it's essential
basically you know so they've got lots
of lots of things to do and go outside
and stimulate the minds and obviously um
you know so there's a lot of things that
that needs doing because at the minute
you know there's no playing field um
it's just basically a yard and obviously
there's a football pitch there that
needs resurfacing as well so a lot of a
lot of work needs going into it really
yeah well
and you all have a fantastic playground
as a result i'm sure the money will will
continue to go and we'll put the just
we'll get we'll talk about the just
giving in just a second and harvey
yesterday when you and i
were talking are we trying to talk it
was your daddy that was sitting next to
you now is he not there this morning
because he's absolutely knackered after
the 15-mile hike is he in an ice bath at
the moment is he getting a massage to
try and make himself feel better yes
yeah that's what i thought that's what i
thought yeah absolutely did you not
could you not have kept him going i mean
you managed to do 15 miles yesterday and
a sprint finish not daddy though
daddy couldn't do it could he yeah you
couldn't
no no
there we go we're just watching looking
at a couple of pictures of you making
your way through the streets of
manchester yesterday just one
one other thing i've got to ask harvey
you're a man you fan that's fine we'll
gloss over it who's your favorite at the
moment who's your favorite player
man united who's your favorite player
when united
collection
fair enough fair enough well if he's
watching i'm sure he might want to see
if he can uh help out and assist with
the donations um so what what's the next
step then mom know me um
are you going to wait for a while just
get cracking on the playground just as
soon as possible yeah i think i think in
the next couple of months everything's
going to get started um so yeah
hopefully not long to wait at all
well look as as the father of a
six-year-old myself the idea of taking
him for a 15-mile hike nah never
happening um so well done harvey i'm
really proud of you mate yeah and i'm
sure your mum and your dad and everyone
else is too so thank you so much for
joining us and well done well done thank
you thank you
take care time to have a final look
through the sunday papers with us to
discuss them the broadcasters and
journalists uh badisha and edward are do
guys good to see you again and i hope
you don't mind i was rather rude to our
previous guests on the program young
harvey i didn't give you guys uh the
just giving page for that it is just
giving harvey dash to dash old trafford
they were trying to raise three thousand
pounds they've raised seven thousand one
hundred and thirty five i'm sure any
extra that could go their way will be
gratefully received um but let's go to
you first at the sarbadesha and we're
talking again national insurance tax
rises and whether or not the tories are
actually thatched right in tax cutting
well you know what the chancellor rishi
sonak and the pm boris johnson insist in
today's sunday times they've got lots of
lovely pages in which they say they are
indeed tax cutting conservatives and
they describe themselves as
bachelorettes it chills me to the bone
that they'll be millennials who are
watching today that don't know uh what
being a thatcherite is they can google
it anyway this is about the
controversial 12 billion pound hike in
national insurance lots of people both
within and without the conservative
party had been very critical and wary
about this proposed move because of
course
inflation is at a 30-year high now
inflation for a quick economics climate
it's the rate at which prices are rising
and we know that ordinary households i
love that phrase it's a very political
place ordinary households all households
are under pressure right now because of
massive rises in food bills and energy
bills because of all the things that
we've been reporting out over the last
few years now what is the one point
something percent uh rise going to
translate to if you're earning around 20
000 pounds a year you'll pay around 89
pounds more if you're earning lucky
enough for you a hundred thousand pounds
a year you'll be paying around a
thousand pounds more in your taxes which
you do from april to april so these
rises are going to come in from the
first week of april onwards
and i have to say that i'm pretty much
on the side of the critics i do
understand of course that
after the few years that we've been
through uh not just to do with covid
there are massive challenges to
everything within britain's economic
system within this article they have
used the time-honored phrase there is no
magic money tree so the reason behind
this hike is pretty obvious the
government needs money i mean there was
no magic money tree apart from all the
quantitative easing we've been doing
over the past couple of years and edward
let's talk about that the lead story for
the observer however and a criticism of
boris johnson's leveling up strategy
coming from and i have to say this you
know lisa nandy who frankly was talking
about this a couple of years before the
tories started
but this
new is this is a bit it's
somewhat confusing because um we'll be
talking about the nr hikes and
this is the government saying we want to
give 20 cities across the country um
money as part of the leveling up now
press release circulated and it popped
up some somewhere from uh michael gove's
department saying uh one a 1.5 billion
brownfield fund uh will be circulated to
different cities and towns now they've
only managed to name two places
sheffield and wolverhampton now they say
that it will benefit um housing leisure
business and sustainable lots of things
around the community now skeptics a lot
of people who are uh skeptical about
this are saying um
is this done was this done because of
what's been going on with the with the
whole party gate saga and obviously
operation big dog and as you say uh lisa
nandy has said that the government has
been caught up trying to spin that extra
money but in actual fact when
looking into the piece um it's not new
funds it's funds which were allocated by
the chancellor rishi sunak uh in the uh
the the budget uh last year so um when
the government were contacted by the
observer they backtracked and said in
actual fact um
you know it was
part of the spending review was funds
released by by the chancellor but it's
just the timing of this i mean it's in
terms of allocating new money to um as
part of the agenda of leveling up it's
great news for some but um it's just the
spin around it which i think a lot of
people are concerned about that in
actual fact it's not new funds yeah yeah
i think that's a very fair point um
padisha take us inside um the sunday
telegraph and tell me just a little bit
more about what what the paper describes
as the collateral damage of covert
restrictions
yes i think we should be very cautious
around this article simply because it is
a sign of the beginning phase of us
looking into creating research around
the true impact on health and social
social welfare of the lockdowns the
pandemic the last two years
the the argument here is that there has
been an up to quadruple increase in
deaths of people who had treatable
conditions so not talking about
palliative care people who
would have been going into their local
gp or their hospital regularly to be
treated during the pandemic time but
because of the pandemic and because of
the strain on the nhs and the disruption
of normal health care practices have had
all of that very vital treatment delayed
there are some quite shocking and
horrifying uh examples within the
article about people who under the first
lockdown in particular died in their own
homes and because they were out of their
usual mix of being in touch with social
carers friends and family were not
discovered for days or weeks on end i
think the takeaway from this because of
course the coroner's reports have to
prove that
had it not been for the lockdown and the
disruption to the nhs these people
wouldn't have died and that causal
relationship that's a legal issue it has
to be very precise
the sign is for me that we are now
looking back on the last two years and
assessing the cost in terms of physical
health and mental health
um do you know what let's let let's try
and raise the nation's spirits a little
bit and end on some slightly more
positive notes edward your final story
um is brilliant inside the sun uh now we
all get a little bit annoyed with the
announcements that come over the uh
tannoy sometimes perhaps not this one
though
so this one this is a funny story about
um
they
that the article it refers to woozy
women which in a sense is is sexist but
it's a group of ladies i would like to
put it mildly and put it in that context
where on the train and the announcer um
asked if anybody had a corkscrew and
i'm not sure whether they
apparently somebody came to their aid
with um
with a swiss knife but it's just been on
a train and you know when i traveled
regularly on trains across the country
and just expecting an announcer to say
um bing bong has anybody got a corkscrew
and i can just imagine some other
passengers thinking hang on a minute is
this is this announcer for real but it's
just it's just a funny story and is this
something that you know it's great to
hear because we you know for a long time
we haven't been able to travel because
of restrictions and people going out and
enjoying themselves and they managed to
manage to make this story happen